la nouvelle tic de sainte marthe sur le
lac est presque terminée et elle est
immense
cinq kilomètres de long et un mètre et
demi plus haute que l'ancien difficile
maintenant d'apercevoir le lac des deux
montagnes où que vous soyez dans la
municipalité serge racette qui habitent
sur le bord de l'eau est frustré badauds
du bas l'ancienne digue qui était
c'était la hauteur le deuxième bandeau
c'est la hauteur proposés par nos
ingénieurs et aussi la hauteur qui a été
choisi par les villes de montagne et
pointe calumet
ce que vous voyez en haut c'est la ville
qu'elle doit déterminer lui une
soixantaine d'autres propriétaires
demandent donc on rabaisse la digue et
ils poursuivent la ville non seulement
là on veut nous cacher la vue ce qui est
une chose mais on va perdre tous les
accès j'y réponds que c'est ce que les
experts nous ont demandé est ce que je
choisis d'aller plus bas et de prendre
le risque de rues inondées l'entière
territoire non et pons et autres
résidents qui ne veut plus revivre le
cauchemar d'avril dernier
jean-françois des chaînes comme beaucoup
ici a dû payer des dizaines de milliers
de dollars de sa poche pour réparer sa
maison on voit sans toujours une
frustration due à la nature de notre
inondations qui était au final un bris
d'une infrastructure publique et non pas
une lourde à son naturel
un an plus tard sainte-marthe fait donc
face à plusieurs autres recours
judiciaires pour avoir mal entretenu son
ancienne digue
le soir du 27 avril 2019
plus de 2500 résidences ont été inondées
en 45 minutes
diane lesage est resté traumatisé je
quitte à se passer
bah la presse du printemps comme ça
sigean fermé comme son sujet revient je
vote ce soir venez par maison comment ça
va un implant malheureusement je obligé
de dire que avec l'aco vide qui se
rajoutent
le temps c'est pas agréable les gens ont
été obligés d'arrêter de faire les
rénovations
quand on voit tous ces terrains
désormais vacants parce que 200 maisons
ont disparu et ses nombreuses autres
encore en chantier avec des travaux
arrêtés
on comprend les résidants de sainte
marthe d'en avoir marre
on n'a ni facile pour s'incliner tu
m'apportes vraiment l'année personne
n'avait pas le droit de venir dans nos
maisons que l'installant de pluton a
sorti à sainte-marthe les résidences
ennuis de vivre peu près temps normal
ici jean-sébastien cloutier radio-canada
sainte marthe sur le lac